[Music]
welcome back to Harbor unboxed now if
you like me need a bit of a break from
all the rise and Madness then I think I
have just the thing an insanely
expensive graphics card yep they always
work a few days ago I took the covers
off nvidia's new GeForce GTX 1080 TI
Founders Edition graphics card in an
unboxing video I covered most of the
specifications in that video so I won't
go over any of that stuff again here for
more details feel free to check out the
written version over at techbot the link
will be included in the video
description a big part of this story
other than the fact that Gamers can now
get Pascal titanex like performance for
$700 is the new $500 MSRP for the
original GTX 1080 as for the 1080 TI
previously this level of performance
cost an eye watering $1,200 us and
knocking a little over 40% off the price
tag is no small thing since the GTX
1080ti won't be anything radically new
in terms of performance especially if
you have the Titan XP added to the mix
like I will there really isn't any need
to test 20 games but this is har unbox
so you know anyway for those of you who
just want to check out the performance
in a few select games feel free to refer
to the video index which I will provide
in a pinned comment as well as a video
description for testing I will be using
my core i77700 K rig which will be
overclocked to 4.9 GHz a few months ago
I moved away from testing stock
reference graphics cards for a few
reasons the main reason being that I
always suggest you guys avoid AMD and
Nvidia reference cards and instead pick
up the quality board partner versions
with bigger coolers that allow the card
to run cooler quieter and boost more
reliably so then the only reference
cards included in the results that
you're about to see include the GTX
1080ti and the Titan XP as you can't get
custom Titan XP cards the rest are
facture overclocked board partner cards
and I will list Which models were used
in the video description I received a
heap of requests to show 1080p results
and although it seems strange to me I'm
going to do it anyway since enough of
you guys asked that said I will quickly
gloss over the 1080P and 1440p results
and focus mainly on the 4K numbers I
have added the few react to the 4K
testing but didn't have time to include
it in the 1080P and 1440p results so
hopefully you guys will let that one
slide there are 61 graphs in total so be
aware of that it's a bit of an
information overload again feel free to
skip to the games that interest you but
if you're like me and think 20 games is
a good little start then let's get on
with it those seeking extreme frame
rates in Battlefield 1 will certainly
receive them at 1080p with the 1080 TI
as it matched the performance of the
Titan XP this was also the case at 1440p
and here in video's new flagship gaming
graphics card pushed well over 100 FPS
at all times now at the 4K resolution
Battlefield 1 looks as sharp as the
edges of a generic ATX case thankfully
though with the 1080 TI in charge of the
rendering work it's a painless
experience experience here we see a
smooth 73 FPS average while frame rates
never dipped below 66 FPS as expected
this again puts it roughly on power of
the Titan XP dropping just a few frames
behind testing with Far Cry Primal at
1080p we run into a rather heavy CPU
bottleneck at 1080p oh hell is it okay
to talk about CPU bottlenecks in this
review hm I'm not quite sure about that
one so to confuse the Fanboys who are
all riled up about CPU bottlenecks at
the moment let's call it a CPU speed
limit instead yeah let's go with that at
1440p the 1080ti again roughly matches
the Titan XP making it 21% faster than
the Santa GTX 1080 not bad results given
frame rate stayed above 80 FPS at all
times moving to 4K the 1080 TI tip toes
ahead of the Titan XP though with just
two FPS in it the performance is
obviously very similar again when
compared to the standard 1080 we are
seeing 20% more performance here even
with the core i7 7700k overclock to 4.9
GHz we start to run into another one of
those pesky CPU speed limits this time
in Call of Duty infinite Warfare at
1080p that said when looking at the
minimum frame rate the 1080 TI still
produced 22% more performance than the
standard 1080 it also looked very Mighty
at 1440p with an average of 117 FPS
while frame rates never di below 100 FPS
at the extreme 4K resolution frame rate
stayed North of 60 FPS with a 1082
pushing no less than 66 FPS throughout
our test that made it 35% faster than
the the vanilla 1080 When comparing the
minimum frame rate which is most
impressive civilization 6 is a rather
CPU demanding game and is therefore
quite well known for imposing CPU speed
limits here we see the 1080 1080ti and
Titan XP capped out at 85 FPS moving to
1440p the highend gpus are still
performance limited even at 4K we find
the higher end gpus all deliver very
similar results the good news here of
course being that all cards tested are
capable of delivering playable
performance at this extreme resolution
du6 mankind divided was tested using the
very high quality preset and here the
1080ti spat out 113 FPS on average
making it a fraction faster than the
Titan XP moving to 1440p it held the
lead over the Titan while providing a
23% greater average frame rate when
compared to the original 1080 those
wanting to play mankind divided at 4K
will likely have to tweak a few settings
as the 35 FPS minimum isn't exactly
desirable not when spending this kind of
money anyway in any case at this
resolution the 1080 TI should be at
least 25% faster than the standard 1080
the division is very demanding on the
GPU as most games are and here we see
that even at 1080p the 1080 TI and Titan
XP will still dip below 80 FPS at times
still with an average of over 120 FPS it
goes without saying that gameplay was
extremely smooth performance remains
very strong at 1440p with over 60 FPS
rendered at all times here we have
another game that will require either
two gpus for a smooth 4K experience or a
reduction in quality settings the 53 FPS
average is actually very good but at
times frame rates drop as low as 31 FPS
in our test Doom enforces its own speed
limit with a 200 FPS hard frame cap
which we are easily reaching on the
highend gpus at 1080p even at 1440p the
1080ti and Titan XP are locked at the
200 FPS frame cap turning up the pixels
at 4K we still see well over 100 FPS at
all times on the Titan XP and GTX 1080ti
as a result this made it 24% faster than
the standard GTX 1080 for the average
frame rate and 20% faster for the
minimum those playing F1 2016 running
triple monitor simulator type setups
will no doubt be very interested in what
the GTX 1080 TI has to offer the 1080p
performance is impressive though it
looks as though we're being held back a
little bit here at 1440p the 1080 tii
starts to pull further away from the
standard 1080 with an average of 133 FPS
now at 4K the 1080 TI is good for 81 FPS
on average while frame rate stayed above
67 FPS at all times this then made
nvidia's new $700 champ 20% faster than
the GTX 1080 cutting your way through
hordes of stupidly easy baddies in
forona is at least slightly satisfying
with the GTX 1080 TI here at 1440p we
see over 80 FPS and this will help you
keep up in the online mode as you change
your guard stance multiple times per
second now at 4K using the extreme
quality preset we are still seeing a
respectable 55 FPS on average this then
was was a 22% performance boost over the
45 FPS churned out by the original GTX
1080 those of you running 144 HZ
monitors can take full advantage of all
those Hertz in Gears of War 4 at 1080p
using the new GTX 1080 TI even at 1440p
frame rates are often seen above 100 FPS
roughly double that of those pathetic
mid-range graphics cards I kid of course
now at 4K we see the fury X and GTX 1070
struggling to keep Pace while the
standard GTX 1080 looks quite
respectable the ti model provides an
additional 24% performance bump hitting
an average of 57 FPS for those of you
new to the channel I should point out
that in some games or certain titles
that support direct X2 I test Nvidia
using DirectX 11 and AMD using direct X2
I have discussed why this is in the past
so I won't go over that again basically
AMD performers better using direct X12
and Nvidia using direct X1 there is no
reason for GeForce owners to use dx12 in
a game that sends performance backwards
for no reason so essentially I'm testing
the API that Gamers will actually use so
using dx11 the GTX 1080ti spits out 130
FPS on average making it a fraction
faster than the Titan XP moving to 1440p
the ti was good for 120 FPS on average
and we are starting to move away from
that tricky CPU speed limit here now at
4K the average frame rate is reduced to
74 FPS with a minimum of 64 FPS and once
again the GTX 1080ti performs very
similar to the Titan XP just a whisk it
slower this also meant it was 29% FAS
than the GTX 1080 using the high quality
preset the 1080 TI pushed an average of
101 FPS at 1080p in Mafia 3 which isn't
bad though that's not much faster than
the standard GTX 1080 moving to 1440p
the ti starts to pull away from the
Plain Jane 1080 though it is only 133%
faster here finally at 4K the 1080 TI
Hits full stride pulling further away
from the standard 1080 by a massive 29%
mark
next up we have the game that made
parkour cool and not the other way
around helping to keep up to speed in
jumping over or underneath things at
maximum efficiency is the GTX 1082 I
with a blistering fast 150 FPS on
average even at 1440p frame rates
average over 100 FPS another nod then
for high refresh rate gaming even at the
4K resolution using the ultra quality
preset the 10802 averaged 57 FPS making
it 24% faster than the GTX 1080 you
probably don't need a GTX 1080 TI Deo
OverWatch but it would be pretty darn
cool to have one anyway frame rates are
pretty insane at 1080P and even at 1440p
we see an average frame rate of around
250 FPS that said this is a very CPU
intensive game and our bot test hammers
even the core i7 7700k overclocked to
4.9 GHz quite hard at 4K the massive
varience between the average and minimum
frame rate is now gone and we're
primarily GPU bound at this point in
other words your typical 4K GPU speed
limit has been applied here firing up
Quantum break we see that the GTX 1082
is able to match the Titan XP as
expected what's interesting here is how
much faster it is than the standard 1080
even at 1080p 22% more performance at
this resolution is quite surprising
moving to 1440p the margin is extended
ever so slightly to 23% and again the ti
is still pushing over 100 FPS finally at
the 4K resolution the 1080 TI is good
for almost 60 FPS on average using the
ultra quality preset that again made it
23% faster than the standard 1080
playing Resident Evil 7 with the 108 tii
we see an incredible 211 FPS on average
at 1080p with the quality settings maxed
out that's more than twice the average
frame rate of the RX 480 and GTX 1060
graphics cards similar margins are seen
at 1440p and again frame rates are kept
well above 100 FPS on nvidia's new $700
graphics card Resident Evil 7 looks
amazing on a large 4K screen and a
single 108 tii can handle the rendering
work no worries as gameplay was silky
smooth at 60 FPS at all times as a
result we saw 24% more frames from the
ti when compared to the standard 1080
rise of the Tomb raer blew us away with
amazing visuals over a year ago now but
even today the game is still one of the
more impressive looking titles although
we don't test a terribly demanding
section of the game the 108 tii still
looks Mighty impressive in relation to
the GTX 1070 for example moving to 1440p
we see that it's 23% faster than the GTX
1080 and Incredibly 55% faster than the
GTX 1070 which as we know is roughly as
fast as last season's Maxwell based
Titan X Tomb Raider is another game that
looks absolutely stunning on a big 4K
screen and the fact that the 1082 I
averages 77 FPS here means that with a
single graphics card you can fully enjoy
the experience here it was 28% faster
than the GTX 1080 Titanfall 2 is a
seriously fast-paced firstperson shooter
so this is a game that would be popular
with 144 Herz owners coincidentally the
1080 TI averaged exactly 144 FPS at
1080p with the quality settings maxed
out even at 1440p we're still seeing an
average of 120 FPS with the 1080 TI now
at 4K the average frame rate has been
heavily reduced as you would expect
still we are seeing an average of 72 FPS
here though this is just 10% faster than
the standard 1080 Total War Warhammer is
a game that I really feel should be
played using the dx12 API regardless of
whether running AMD or Nvidia Hardware
like ashes of the singularity during the
battles when there are masses of units
on screen the CPU takes a good old
pounding when using dx11 anyway even on
dx12 the GTX 1080ti is still Mighty fast
pushing over 100 FPS at all times at
1080p at 1440p frame rates are again
very strong and we often saw frame rates
exceeding 100 FPS now finally at 4K the
average frame rate has been heavily
reduced as you would expect still with
an average of 65 FPS it was an
impressive 30% % faster than the
standard 1080 finally Watch Dogs 2 this
is the last game I've tested I promise
despite being a hugely demanding game on
system resources aka unoptimized the GTX
1082 I still manages to reach 100 FPS on
average even at 1440p frame rates remain
high and nvidia's new GPU is still good
for 91 FPS allowing it to match the
Titan XP moving to 4K the 1082 is still
23% faster than the original 1080 as it
went on to reach an average of 59 FPS
when compared to the GTX 1080 the 1080
TI consumed just 7% more power pushing
the total system consumption to 334 wats
which is surprisingly low keep in mind
we are using a custom board partner
version for the GTX 1080 GB G1 gaming
but even then that's an impressive
result for the 1080 tii that also means
it's using less power than the fury X
despite delivering considerably more
performance interestingly though when
compared to the Titan XP the 1080 TI
reduced total system consumption by 8%
which is more than I expected to see now
I wouldn't say nvidia's GTX 1080 TI
Founders Edition graphics card is loud
when gaming but you can certainly hear
it over your case fans underload the fan
ran at 50% capacity which sees it
spinning at 2400 RPM the thing pumps out
some serious heat as well load temps
quickly reached 80° before maxing out at
84° at this temperature the card would
hold an operating frequency of at least
1670 MHz please do note that when I
unboxed the GTX 1080ti a few days ago I
did remove the cooler and wipe the
thermal paste off to show you guys the
die the paste was replaced with
something that looked quite similar
though there's no guarantee that
wouldn't impact thermals one way or the
other as it turns out I don't think this
influenced the results too much Kevin
over at Tech Showdown confirmed
operating temperatures of around
83° well if you came on that 20 game
Benchmark Journey with me I didn't skip
ahead at any point and sat through all
the benchmarks that I guess it's safe to
say you're having a pretty slow day
anyway I enjoyed checking out those
games and I hope you did too uh before
we wrap things up let's just summarize
how the GTX 1080ti fared against the
standard 1080 as well as the fury X for
those of you who didn't have time to sit
through all 20 games when compared to
the original GTX 1080 or the G1 gaming
model that we use for testing which was
released almost a year ago now the new
TI model was on average 22% faster we
did see it deliver up to 30% more Prof
performance in titles such as Dex
mankind divided and Total War Warhammer
that set at 4K their gains were
sometimes as little as 10% still for the
most part as that average figure
suggests the 108 tii delivered between
20 and 25% more performance that said it
does come in at around 40% more
expensive than the GTX 1080 but of
course that's the premium you pay for
high-end gaming and with no alternative
there's no need for NVIDIA to be more
aggressive on pricing at least for now
anyway the fury X is just about eligible
for the pension at this point as it's
just a few months off its second
birthday 2 years is a long time to sit
at the top of your product stack as the
flagship offering anyway the GTX 1082 I
puts the furyx down in the most humane
way possible quickly dispatching of it
with 61% more performance on average as
a side note I believe what we're seeing
here is the fury X running into a vram
capacity issue at 4K in Doom and that's
why it gets pced in a game where you
would expect it to do significantly
better than it did as noted in a video I
created about a month ago unless you can
pick up a fury X graphics card for $300
us or less I wouldn't bother at that
price the 108 tii is obviously more than
twice as expensive and it's not twice as
fast that said it's really gpus such as
the GTX 1070 that make the fury x a bad
buyer at over $300 for those of you
wondering I will be putting together an
in-depth overclock benchmarking video
soon I didn't really have time to cover
that here or more I didn't want to
stretch the video out any longer than I
have and I figured overclocking is
usually best in its own video uh but I
don't expect much out of the founders
Edition card anyway I'm guessing we'll
squeeze maybe 10% more performance out
as we are running pretty close as it is
out of the box to that 91° threshold uh
I imagine overclocking will be a lot
better or at least better on a a custom
board partner card featuring a nice big
cooler something like what a gigabyte
will produce with their Aus product line
it's really the board partner cards that
will make the GTX 1080ti truly exciting
in my opinion pricing aside the Titan XP
is a seriously nice graphics card uh
well nice GPU as the graphics card only
comes with the reference cooler which
runs extremely hot too hot to handle
after a short gaming session and for me
that kind of spoils it obviously we need
not worry about the Titan XP anymore as
the GTX 1080ti offers the same kind of
performance while shaving a little over
40% off the asking price right now the
1080ti is the ultimate 4K gaming
solution or really just the ultimate
gaming solution as 1440p 144 HZ Gamers
will also be chomping at the bit to get
their hands on one until AMD releases
Vega I really don't expect to see any
kind of shift in the GPU landscape still
knocking the vanilla GTX 1080 down to
$500 US from the original $600 us asking
price is a huge win for consumers for us
Aussies it is now possible to purchase
the GTX 1080 locally for just $700 AUD I
suspect Nvidia has done this to create a
huge Buzz around high end parts they
really enjoyed strong sales and profits
in 2016 thanks to the GTX 1080 and 1070
or well the whole Pascal lineup really
if I'm honest I imagine they are trying
to recapture that magic once again in
2017 and I see no better way of doing
that than cutting the GTX 1080 down to
$500 and then bringing in a really
impressive part like they have with the
ti or the 1080 TI at $700 and this will
probably help take away a bit of ATT
tension from from amd's upcoming Vega
anyway the GTX 1080 TI is mighty
expensive at
$700 uh near where was I uh what was my
note right I'm talking about the price
uh mighty expensive at $700 and I'm not
going to deny that is a very expensive
graphics card but at the same time it's
also delivering performance that we've
really has been unheard of at this price
you can't get anything else that
delivers nearly the same level of
performance for $700 so Nvidia will
certainly get away with charging that
price and I imagine as this video goes
live there'll be people somewhere in the
world lining up to get their hands on
one of these for the equivalent of $700
us um speaking of which locally when you
guys or the Australians wake up on
Friday morning and head down to their
favorite retailer to try and pick one of
these up the rumor is you will be stung
around $1,200 AUD which is quite a bit
above the straight conversion from US
dollars to Aussie dollars so yeah we're
getting stung quite a price premium on
top of the price premium for this card
uh but it is suggest that you'll
probably add a land one for about $1,000
AUD from Amazon or new EG so keep that
in mind bit sad that we can buy it so
much cheaper after having paid shipping
from the US ourselves um and yeah that
kind of may have problems with warranty
if you need to warranty the card down
the track but anyway that's what it is
yeah $700 I still think it is a great
value product for highend Extreme Gaming
for now I'm Keen to get my hands on a
custom GTX 1080 TI graphics card uh cuz
yeah I think they're going to be a lot
more impressive as they often are bigger
coolers and whatnot so yeah I'll be
grabbing one of them as soon as possible
hopefully in a week or two and bringing
you a review as quick as I can get that
together so with that I'm going to go
harass my contacts now I'm your host
Steve hope to catch you again soon
oh
[Music]